[Music]
and we're here now to talk about what's
happening on Sunday because it is epic
game of Thrones finally back the wait is
over it's so hard to wait right
everybody but it's always so worth it
and yeah you're gonna get you ready
because we've got everything you need to
know about this new season winter is
officially here and that's why we had to
wait next 2-3 months for the premiere of
season 7 the shooting locations need to
go gray and gloomy but for fans
disappointed that season 7 will be just
seven episodes instead of 10 there is a
piece of good news we're getting our
longest episode ever the finale with 81
minutes I was born to rule the Seven
Kingdoms and I win we know the mother of
dragons Emilia Clarke will make it to
the end of season seven after recently
revealing she will be in season eight
the show's last and she's just as
excited as fans to find out who will sit
on the Iron Throne when the final season
starts shooting this fall so when you
get a scrape for getting the crowns and
you just immediately length up looking
through it and find out what's happening
now yes I'm like the biggest fan of the
show it's ridiculous I have to read
everything this season is a departure
from the book so to reduce the risk of
spoilers no screeners were sent to the
press and their father and brothers are
gone and here you stand last best hope
against the coming storm but sophie
turner who dyes her hair red to play
Sansa Stark gives us little scoop all of
the characters will be linking up to
stop preparing some sounds fern
heads so expect bigger drama bigger
stakes and bigger dragons they're now
the size of 747 airplanes the crazy
dragon stuff happens the whole thing's
amazing and that's what I can say well
now hold on a second Sophie because
we're getting some more goods we're
sitting down with some of the cast again
for all new interviews and we will have
[Music]
you